[Musica]
devo chiamarla io prima dell'alba
arrivato già al secondo terzo è questo
il mondo siamo 7 miliardi a 645 neanche
la metà di narita eravamo 3 miliardi e 8
chiamo raddoppiati in età di una vita ma
soprattutto quando è cominciato il
nostro modello sociale 200 anni fa si
chiama società dei consumi eravamo un
miliardo si è passati da un miliardo a 7
degli anni due secoli e
un'impressionante scalese siamo divisi
cento e 98 staff metà di questi sono
dittatoriali e metà sono democratici
parliamo 125 macro lingue e una marea
milioni
siamo per 40 per cento gialli per il 21
per cento marrone per un per il 21 per
cento neri per il 18 per cento bianchi
ci sono 24 macroregioni ma ciascuna di
queste divisa in diverse strade sono
cristianesimo cene 8 per il ritorno di
leader cinesi
potremmo seguire in 4 marco branca del
resto quindi si può dire che c'è un
centinaio di veri sono diversi il 35 per
cento analfabeta 70 per cento vedo in
casa e senza abitabilità 42 stati sono
interessate le guerre
quindi possiamo cavare che circa due
miliardi di persone vivono perennemente
in guerra siamo bio diversi quando un
milione di anni fa si è partiti dalle
leggi ovvio siamo incominciato a salire
lomu sappia se a distribuirsi del mondo
abbia cambiato colore
abbiamo cambiato stesse e poi è nata
l'immaginazione e quindi ci siamo
inventati la lezione politica siamo via
diversi alla meraviglia della
biodiversità mano e poi infine notizia
principale di donne credo che magari
magari non tutti lo sapete è una notizia
formidabile
nessuno di noi decide dove nascere
nessuno di noi 10 da quando nascere in
che fanno i danari nessuno di noi decide
e sesso nessuno di noi deciderlo
orientamento sessuale
lo rispetto molto ultimamente perché se
ti giro tanta gente che fa dei
ragionamenti come se avesse deciso l'oro
di nascerà pato ma piuttosto caratta
piuttosto che ad aleppo e tutti i
ragionamenti sono passati sul fatto che
loro hanno deciso di nascere dal nord
slot interiano notizia 20 per cento dei
cittadini del mondo non tanto per cento
del cosiddetto pil patrini sentiamo
all'interno l'un per cento che possiede
il 50 per cento
questo al mondo e la meraviglia della
biodiversità è una meraviglia delle
nostre imperfezioni l'imperfezione umana
che se ne prendiamo atto
siamo capaci di gestirli viviamo
serenamente provochiamo benessere
se invece continuiamo a cercare la
perfezione è un casino
avremo sempre fiducia degli altri
seducendo stessi ciò scritto un libro
che dietro punto quasi per spiegare che
siamo tutti quasi e dobbiamo prenderne
atto
allora facciamo così al posto di psiche
diciamo sentimenti umani al posto di
tecne diciamo invenzioni perché parlo
molti sentimenti umani
chi lamenta perché ho capito nel tempo e
con esperienza che l'unica maniera di
lavorarci lavorando sui sentimenti umani
perché per cambiare per diventare
migliori per le regole già esistono
c'era vengono che hanno seduta per terra
sia la regola che non si scrive sui muri
c'è una regola che non si parcheggia in
doppia fila c'è l'articolo 10 della
costituzione che dice che dobbiamo cosi
alle persone in difficoltà da tutto il
mondo
c'è la regola bisogna fare la
differenziata ci sono le regole se il
fermarla una difende dal male dei
sentimenti umani sono molto interessanti
perché arriva dalla testa della pancia e
al cuore e creare in pesci i pensieri e
il rapporto con gli stessi tra noi i
pensieri c'è un apporto straordinario
perché non tutti i pensieri diventano
parole ma molte lo dimettono e le parole
poi si trasformano i comportamenti che
alla fine si concretizzano in azioni
ed è per questo che occorre lavorare i
suoi sentimenti umani per capire anche
come si sono evoluti dimentichiamo che
poi c'è un'altra parte della stretta
bellissima di sono i sogni sui quali non
viene chiesto a fermarci e ragionarci
perché forse sono quelli che ci ci
rappresentano meglio proviamo a fare in
pochissimi minuti un viaggio di un
milione e mezzo
da 600mila generazioni fa a oggi per
capire come si sono evoluti sentimenti
umani
cominciamo dal museo del fuoco milione e
mezzo di anni fa negli occhi all'alto lì
il problema erano leoni thigpen note
viola ma per gli umani vedono che tigri
leoni scappano si chiamava fede
quell'enorme quell'uomo scimmie ma
prendere quello che lo porta a casa e di
lì parte una storia straordinaria
lei soffermate di sun i sentimenti
positivi che sono i più interessanti e
notate che sono quasi tutti ancora
animaleschi primordiale ce n'è uno che
nasce un po più dalla misurazione che la
curiosità e guardate le invenzioni da
ristorante psiche sentimenti umani
positivi tenne le versioni di
applicazioni fuoco cultura ma nasce la
riunione
nasce il primo linguaggio saltiamo a 15
mila anni fa altro grandissimo
invenzione l'agricoltura confini fra
l'iraq l'iran la siria la mesopotamia
non essere una fertile un'invenzione
straordinaria il capo di una famiglia
decide di smettere di andare in giro a
fare il calciatore raccoglitore a
prendere provare prendere quel se a
metterlo per terra a bagnarli
aspettare e vedere cosa succedeva una
meraviglia assoluta
guardate i sentimenti umani positivi la
pazienza la perseveranza della viglia la
prima forma di amore che contempla anche
la natura perché c'è il primo rapporto
diretto e produttivo per l'uomo la
natura e guardate che invenzioni
strardinaria agricoltura la
conservazione della cucina era chiaro
che la prima grande civiltà della
sciarelli tran tigri delle fratte su
mesi straordinari questi inventano la
scrittura le leggi l'aritmetica la ruota
inventano tutto e quali erano i loro
grandi sentimenti umani positivi
incominciate a vedere che sono tutti i
frutti dell'immaginazione c'è di noi che
ci stacchiamo agli animali
aiutiamo scegliere risolto problema del
cibo perché i diecimila anni
l'agricoltura era andata molto avanti
soprattutto in quel luogo e cominciano
le prime delle religioni organizzate la
mozione le prime delle strutture
politiche organizzate che la devozione
sia verso il re che verso dio senso del
futuro ottimismo interessa un po più a
nord è un po più a ovest d'egitto gli
egiziani riescono costruire un unico
impero mentre i sumeri erano città stato
e si inventano il massimo e cominciano
quelli in anime tanto scrittura fronti
da questi le mettono finalmente sulla
caccia a coprire in mente ad herat
rosolatura la catena di montaggio se non
col cavolo che facevano quelle piramidi
a luxor e in tempi che ben conosciamo
vedete anche il primo make up sia per i
maschi che per le femmine poi noi
maschietti
lo abbiamo abbandonato ed è femmina
guardate cosa inventano il pensare in
grande è l'entusiasmo la fratellanza e
la nostalgia con i sentimenti umani
straordinaria quando mi chiedono in che
presti essere nato avrei detto la grecia
di perché è incredibile sono vissuti più
o meno che dopo lana per i tre sopra che
platone aristotele e in mezzo la
bellezza l'arte in man cano la
metafisica che aiuterà poi all'interno
romano che era già il popolo meglio
nutrito quindi più forte che ha
conquistato i territori guardate con
sera l'italia allora guardate la parte
rossa d'italia la numero uno al mondo ma
non solo come gli stati uniti oggi e
questi mettere mettano l'acquedotto
l'agricoltura moderna attraverso
ambienti 3d e mezzo tutta l'ingegneria
le strade in centro un gol mio
patriottismo pensare globale ma poi dopo
la battaglia di corinto 146 matic li sto
parlando dei greci anche sentimenti
umani metafisici quindi si mettono la
dignità se la pietas che c'è qui tutta
la storia di traiano sulla istituzione
mentario periodo negativo non vorrei mai
essere nate in questo momento terribile
quindi qui guardate solo quelli negativi
e non fate paragoni giorni nostri a mi
raccomando sfiducia presunzione di
disonestà collettiva ci sono tutti i
disonesti tra le me naturalmente
bellicosità le maniche di prud non si
chiama dichiarando guerra all'europa c'è
mi sembra di risentire riuscimmo a 140
dichiararla alla francia alla gran
bretagna
per non farci mancare niente gli stati
uniti d'america la russia e tutti quella
generazione di italiani li applaudiva
questa scelta bellicosità e pensiamo in
cui mettono praticamente un tubo il
mulino tutto il pil si trasferisce
nell'est 85 per cento del pd quel
momento nel mondo era della cina e
dell'india che fra escono crescono e
dominano il mondo per sei sette otto
secoli qui da noi c'era carlo magno che
faceva incominciava il discorso delle
crociate che poi si realizzano le nostre
colonne altro periodo pazzesco
rinascimento ritorna la fiducia ritorna
all umanesimo l'uomo centro del mondo
invenzione straordinaria autonomia lato
mia prospettiva le insegne che belli
fiducia stima commozione generosità
orgoglio
scopriamo il mondo il piz si trasferisce
in europa a di franz i cinesi si sentiva
i numeri al mondo e non erano curiosi è
l'elemento fondamentale la curiosità noi
europei
scopriamo il mondo addirittura gli ok al
gran bretagna scopre australia con
milano azzera né che a due passi dalla
cina da sotto e tutte le americhe di
mettiamo i problemi del mondo noi gli
europei
scatta la rivoluzione industriale siamo
200 anni fa si inventa la macchina a
vapore parte una storia incredibile
iniziali modello sociale attuale che si
chiama se stai con su nel triangolo
semplice per esempio sul pregresso
potere
allarme corso consumando un po di più
nuovi posti lavoro migliori salari
eccetera non sperare che questi due
centrali ci ha aumentato la vita media
di 20 anni e ha distribuito un po meglio
la ricchezza
all'inizio l'uno avrà 99 adesso al 20
all 80 ma sempre male e ragazzi avete
avuto tutti un colpo di culo pazzesco
siete nati visto che non avete deciso se
c'è qualcuno che ha deciso anzi la mafia
va invece procede morti che sembra
cambia del cibo
bene bene siete nati come un milione e
mezzo di anni fa fuoco rivoluzione
digitale 1965 jobs emozion 1975 stesso
anno bill gates e paul allen e poi ti ne
sono e poi per darli poi nasce questa
cosa straordinaria che se ben gestita da
effetti straordinari se mal gestita
guardate uguale al fuoco le grandi
invenzioni alla fine facciamo fatica
tristi allora ma tante cose che ho messo
fatto un asse cartesiano e vi ho messo i
sentimenti più importanti negativi in
rosso più importanti positivi delle
delle 11 epoche che ho analizzato e vi
ho fatto vedere anche il tecnico cioè
guardate come il sole di edile oggi che
è il wigan sentimento positiva la voglia
di libertà e purtroppo è purtroppo
conferiamo con il pettegolezzo che una
storia un po strana nel mondo del web
questi sono i cinque sentimenti secondo
me sui quali noi italiani e soprattutto
quei giovani dovete concentrarvi per
cambiare questo non sia ora che è la più
fortunata del mondo
al 70 per cento del patrimonio artistico
romanità 50 per cento
al 53 patrimonio dell'unesco altri
grande biodiversità agroalimentare mano
a uscire da questa cappa di fiducia di
pesce vivo cinque mosse o un minuto per
dirle invece di spiegarle vi leggo
quattro righe che ho scritto per uno di
questi temi di saper gestire la propria
imperfezione
secondo me siamo tutti torno di pisa
vediamo giunti ma non cadiamo ed è
questo non è la verità
adoro quasi l'incompiuto il copiato il
meno peggio su per giù mi ispira che ho
promesso che trova il set perfetto amo
sbagliare ma non troppo vincere mi fa
godere ma senza esagerare
mentre a provarci sempre e comunque
quando anche sia ignorati arrivarci
vicino quasi giudici quasi in tempo
quasi perfetto quasi guerriero a mi
avete tolto le slide bruton avevo molti
record grazie perché per acquisire
coraggio dovete pensare locale dire
globale siete nati in italia
giusto siete contenti del sernato
d'italia perché una figata però anche su
altri aspetti ebbene ho scritto una
lettera d'amore al nostro paese con le
tue curve con quelle commesse ti disegni
ron e di come se il mio cuore non
vedesse linee spigoli che pur andati per
quanto sei bella ti ricorderò male mia
dolci profumi e luminosa stella ma anche
i punti oscuri e pratolino tu sei la
meraviglia del testo susiti narrano
amore mio
tutto ciò che di tempo ormai ferra
raccontarlo solo io merito non option to
mi fa perdonare moreno dovrò combattere
col coraggio di galileo dir la verità
quanto
e quando smetterà implementati quel
giorno tornerò amore mio riuscirò senza
bene finalmente da martin quel giorno
con te ci poteva stare di tangeri allora
ti rispetto
bisogna trasformarlo il senso del dovere
ma trasferito dal valore del rispetto va
trasferito al sesso dove era il senso
del piacere frondi oggi to the beauty
per risolvere questo qui fatta e fatica
a capire chi è più giovane dei due vero
guardate pertini quando il segreto per
restare giovani poi uscite già ma lo
diventerete sempre di meno nei prossimi
anni fa centro cofa restare giovani
eliminare la parola io dal vostro
popolare notate i vecchi dicono sempre
yo yo yo qualunque roma e si è riusciti
a eliminare st parola ultima sly l'unica
maniera per inventare copiare
con hetemaj concreti del frutto guardate
questa foto scelte sicuri che lei che
copia e lo sa magari lei prima di ha
passato il compito è ora tra controllato
sono affatto bene in ogni caso sono
bellissime e meravigliosi se riuscite a
connettere le vostre menti se riuscite
connetteremo strumenti che avete un
grande futuro
commette mai scritti definito è il motto
di dubai 20 eventi questi arabi che nell
83 si sono trovati senza petrolio
l'unico metramo il mondo senza petrolio
sottocenerina hanno aspettato e sperato
forte ma non è solo aumenti oggi dubai
al doppio three turisti di roma mi
sembra una roba normale
chiudo con questo abito l'ho con gli ha
prescritto dedicata al tema del copiare
che si intitola io copio non metto copio
ma non vado mica in america la mia
tecnica e più selvatica scoprire dalle
imprese piccoline che spesso soccorsa di
merck co più dei semplici mi sento
complici copie dei bambini loro hanno i
delfini con più dei timidi hanno
pensieri cambi li compio dai migliori
sanno riconoscere gli errori coke e dei
miei figli dai loro amici meglio il ciò
che dicono di ciò che dici concluda le
piazze nei mercati dei sorrisi delle
facce copie dei vegetali nei pesci degli
animali coppie dalle cose rotte riesco
perfino a copiare dai miei sogni la
nobili completa chi è triste e da che
felici copie da qualsiasi cosa si dice
copia delle sedie tavoli tende copie da
chi non si arrende
lo ammetto mi piace copiare il server
per migliorare mano lungo non imito
copio ringrazio e mi sento pronto ad
essere a mia volta a cui piace
vorrei pareggiava tra preso e dato tutto
adra
naturalmente